I actually meant to text you because I
was thinking about this story and I was
like bro what are the what are the odds
that Joe or like someone in that Network
sold those people some of those animals
you know what I mean because it seems
like to obtain those animals you have to
be thin like a specific like a certain
group you know like it seems like it was
borne out of like a group of people 20
30 years ago when owning exotic animals
really wasn't illegal like there were no
laws around it so these people are sort
of like grandfathered in because they
they owned them in that time period and
they kind of grew up with it and know
how to obtain them and now it's probably
really [ __ ] hard if at all and so I
mean I don't know I you got if you got a
figure like there is a connection there
like maybe it's not sure erect you know
maybe I kept theory I kept thinking I
was gonna hear about the place that we
went in the show like cuz ya be not that
many like you know sanctuaries or zoos
or whatever like there's probably a
handful of them you know with men yeah
sorry let's cut you off I wonder if the
whole obsession because I like in
Eastern mysticism Tigers you know they
have they have like sort of spiritual I
want to say value but it's like they
they have meaning that's what I'm trying
to say you know in like like you'll see
images of like Swami's and stuff like
meditating on like tiger skin or like
whatever and so I wonder if these people
sort of they get one and and and some of
them find their way to like I don't know
like yoga or like Hinduism or something
and then they start to like in their
head make these weird connections like I
meditate with my Tigers I am [ __ ]
connected to God now and then it just
becomes this Jam where I am a god yeah
then they started saying [ __ ] like I
reincarnated my tiger and also mother
Gaia is living in the [ __ ] dojo over
there and you need to kiss her stomach
before you leave
also I am allowed to have eight wives
yeah yeah I think they're all
polygamists - what the [ __ ] is that
oh yeah yeah [ __ ] is that such like some
self-serving [ __ ] I think I've told this
story before but it is relevant and I'll
make it really quick I had a my first
developer job one of my co-workers told
me that he had a buddy who had joined a
cult
no no Tigers but he had joined some cult
and he joined the cult with his wife and
that was the premise for the cult was
that the leader could have sex with
anyone regardless of the woman's
relationship with whoever and so the guy
heading up the cult sent this dude to go
buy bonbons and then the dude had an
epiphany while buying these bonbons that
this guy was [ __ ] his wife well he
was buying the bonbons and I guess he
walked from the whole thing like in that
moment like he was like man [ __ ] this
yeah I don't know the specifics of when
he got out but I was just like we used
to just die laughing at that cuz yeah
here's your bonbons mister yeah Lord
buying them after sex treats like it's
like late of and you're like you're you
but no was specifically funny because
the company we worked at it was like
there they did all types of ad media in
the building and so like there were
there like factory workers and whatever
so we had this these massive vending
machines and they sold crazy [ __ ] in
there one of them was just like ice
cream and there were bonbons in that
[ __ ] so then we just used to buy them
all the time and like laughs as we ate
them and give me giving it to each other
yeah yeah a man got you some bonbon this
thanks for [ __ ] my wife dude yeah
that's yeah bro oh wait wait wait
yeah so Carol yeah wife kill her husband
killer do you think she did it I do
think she did she was good worst one
dude she was the worst one I hate
her more than the other people no she
was a oh what a self entitled thing she
said made my skin just crawl so I said
so I meant self-important like she was
just so [ __ ] I just had her nose in
the air about everything it's like man
who the [ __ ] are you you are no
different you are no different than
these other people who want to own these
Tigers and you know you do it under the
guise of sort of I'm helping but it's so
insane to be like yeah only I deserve to
take care of big cats because I know how
to do it why because you loved big cats
since you were young that's that's
everyone else yeah I mean though what
really what really like made it clear to
me that she's the exact same was you
know there there she this this woman
basically it was like lobbying for like
the Ethical Treatment of big cats and
not to not to breed them and not to sell
them and stuff like that and so she
rescues them from places that do that
from places that breed them and sell
them to like celebrities and stuff like
that she'll rescue these cats and then
they live on her zoo and she'll take
people out charged them for tours
yeah and [ __ ] like that but then all of
her workers are [ __ ] volunteers she
doesn't pay them a cent if she has like
a hundred people working for her like on
Christmas and [ __ ] like that
[ __ ] you yeah he's a dog [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of here oh and her [ __ ] weak ass
that guy I've never you thought of the
word betta in a serious way I look at
that dude that's the first time I
actually used that word on my holy [ __ ]
this dude is beta is [ __ ] he's a Cobra
big Center first time I've been able to
like use that word legitimately he's a
simp dude the way he just sort of like
just hangs his teeth on ER and [ __ ]
just sucks and eats everything she says
and like makes it his opinion is [ __ ]
foul like what oh what a spineless
little [ __ ] that guy is yeah I mean
the very first thing you hear from him
in the show is I will do everything I
can to make Carol happy no matter what
the conditions oh and you're like what
yeah we don't even know you dude say
I or something introduce yourself maybe
that's his identity I I'm the man but
does what Carol wants and I will get her
bonbons if she chooses yeah so desires
them I think the big the biggest thing I
took from the doc was man so I think
making a murderer was interesting
because it exposed basically all these
people in major cities who don't
understand the Midwest or like that
weird [ __ ] goes on is like what do the
justice system is [ __ ] up and I feel
like Netflix is in this thing with
documentaries like that where they just
have to keep like one upping you know
that I feel like the next big one was
wild wild country this big cult that
like had its own nation like or like was
trying to form its own territory and
[ __ ] like that's crazy yeah and now
they're here with these stories of
people who are so specific and so wild
you know it's like oh this [ __ ] like
writes itself kind of thing right yeah
what the [ __ ] good yeah well what the
[ __ ] can they do after this like they're
in this shitty position where they can't
beat the last thing they made I feel
like or like you know they can clearly
but it just takes more and more
intensity like the next one has to be
you know proving that coronavirus was an
engineered weapon like that's the only
yeah yeah yeah coronavirus was a it was
a weapon invented by a polygamist who
also owned Tigers yeah and formed a cult
and was wrongfully incarcerated for the
murder of of Steven Avery or whatever
Teresa Halbach yeah yeah it's the Marvel
Universe of [ __ ] documentary
characters from Netflix oh my god is is
it's joe the tiger king he's with his
tigers and monkeys it's him and the
villain the villains are Doc anal
Carol and wait was that guy's last name
annal antal hay and tanto I thought it
was anal for a second doc no no that's
so that'll be his name doc aim doc anal
yeah his doc anal Carol the husband
killer yep and the the rajneeshees
and like they're they're the evil right
and as joe and then who's who's Steven
Avery's son or whatever III know I never
watched that one you didn't what now I
didn't watch that is that to make a
murderer yeah making a murder I'd making
a murderer yeah I didn't watch that one
I watched like the first couple episodes
I think hold on look dude I go and
[ __ ] zero from Dreams of Sushi that's
yeah flicks one is it yeah that's not an
that he's a good he's one of the good
guys he's one of the good guys who the
[ __ ] else Brendan Dassey that's his name
Brendan Dassey
now look up look up Brendan Dassey real
quick alright so here's what I'm
picturing I'm picturing Joe in like the
[ __ ] final scene from The Avengers
where they have like the big war and
they open up the portal - like what
Conda and [ __ ] Brendan Dassey dude he
was like he is the basis of making a
murderer
he supposedly was like a witness to
Steven Avery like killing I don't know
somebody I forget now at this point but
my main thing here is Brendan loved
wrestling okay
so Joe comes in and he lets the animals
out they open up a portal to his [ __ ]
Zoo in Florida and he comes running
through that [ __ ] with all these Tigers
he's like all the Tigers and the monkeys
go out and start beating doc and his Vic
Vic Vixens asses and then Brendan Dassey
comes from the top like through a portal
from the top rope out of his cell and he
can he comes down with a cage over Carol
and he gets in a cage match
with Carol and Doc annal and he wins by
way and then what's Jiro doing just
chopping sushi on the side no he's like
cutting sushi and he's feeding everyone
making sure they're yeah they're good to
fight we should sell this idea dude
that's the only way they're gonna be
able to top it with that I'm a natural
next step for them they make a pro
wrestling league out of all these
[ __ ] villains they've created in the
world oh my [ __ ] god dude
tonight's hell in the cell Brendan
Dassey versus Doc anal
[Laughter]
you